the most important thing about the look
was the use of black and white I
remember being asked do you think we
should shoot in black and white or color
and I said black and white without even
a hesitation Bob did some eight
millimeter color footage of him in the
gym working out and we looked at him one
night we ran it in my apartment we just
ran on a white door we just ran the
eight millimeter footage and Michael
Powell the Great British director one
night he was there we're running one
evening running this little eight
millimeter footage of sparring to Nero
sparring where one of the guys Howell
looked and said the gloves went wrong
color of the gloves I said you're right
they're bright red of course at the
period I think the gloves are more
Oxblood or maroon in a way hi and even
Marty who's younger than I associate
boxing with black and white because of
uh the pictures that you saw in Life
magazine and the old news reels and and
the Friday Night Fights but it suddenly
hit me the color ugh I said you know I
love color movies I'm obsessed with
color but when he said that the gloves
are wrong it hit me and so that's when
we decided I said let's make it black
and white